imagine that you were sent a cool
package with an Amazon gift card and a
USB flash drive in your head you already
see how to spend this money and without
suspecting anything evil you insert the
flash drive into the computer and
you got scammed by genius social
engineering and that's how in 2021 one
of the most dangerous hacking groups fin
7 stole millions of dollars once victims
plugged in the bad USB flash drive it
intercepted keystrokes and captured
screenshots and hackers were able to
infiltrate points of Sales Systems and
steal card information FBI courts and
members of Finn seven and arrested them
but not before stealing millions of
dollars and compromising credit card
information let's be honest would you
insert such a flash drive or resist it
to know more about social engineering
and various attacks watch our videos
[Music]